peligrosamente cerca del punto de
ruptura esta es la advertencia de los
funcionarios de salud brasileños luego
de que el país registrar el jueves más
de 2.000 muertes por el virus en una
misma jornada por segunda fecha
consecutiva un hito sombrío que ha
provocado preocupación e ira en las
calles de río de janeiro
el presidente debería haber tomado
medidas en lugar de eso le dijo a la
gente que no usará mascarilla ni se
vacunará no creo que la situación
seguirá empeorando y la gente se
preocupara más porque no vemos una
solución inmediata sino más sólo soy
lidiar a medida que los hospitales
alcanzan su máxima capacidad en las
principales ciudades las autoridades
locales se esfuerzan por detener el
aumento de los casos impulsado por una
variante más contagiosa que surgió en la
región amazónica
brasilia la capital donde se están
instalando hospitales de campaña para
hacer frente al exceso de pacientes ha
implementado un toque de queda nocturno
río de janeiro tiene horarios de
apertura restringidos para bares y
restaurantes en sao paulo sólo las
empresas esenciales
pueden permanecer abiertas la ciudad más
poblada del país también aplicó un toque
de queda cerró sus playas y parques y
prohibió los servicios religiosos y
eventos deportivos hospitais listón
nuestros hospitales están en peligro
compromete fallos de varios de ellos ya
han alcanzado el 100 por ciento de su
capacidad los 100 por ciento de su
pasión
las autoridades locales dicen estar
luchando para alentar el cumplimiento
público ya que sus esfuerzos están
siendo socavados por jair bolsonaro el
presidente se niega a hacer cumplir las
restricciones y siempre ha minimizado la
amenaza del virus entretanto la campaña
de vacunación de brasil ha tenido un
lento comienzo menos del 5 por ciento de
la población ha recibido una primera
dosis